why is cinema chain investing in gold do
you remember amc it was a big meme stock
last year the market capitalization
jumped from about four billion dollars
to more than 30 billion dollars in the
space of just a few weeks well the ceo
adam aaron has just announced plans to
invest about 30 million dollars in a
gold mine and it says something quite
interesting about how he perceives his
own company's prospects you see the role
of ceo is often to do with capital
allocation in other words how you spend
your investors money in a way that will
generate the best possible returns for
them and usually you can do one of three
things you can either invest in the
existing business by opening new
locations investing in innovations
adding new head count you can think
about acquiring a company that
will then play well with your existing
companies and the two firms work better
together than they would on their own
and thirdly you can just return that
money to investors now he's not opting
to do any of those things
returning money to investors would be a
strange choice because he only raised on
them last year and besides
amc trades at a considerable premium to
its competitors so it's not necessarily
buying shares at a reasonable price
when it comes to investing in
adjacent deals or the existing business
he's sort of telling investors that i
can't find a way of generating as good a
return as i could by investing in this
goldmine in other words the implicit
suggestion is cinema business is not
very good and you should put your money
elsewhere he's just cutting out the
middleman and doing it himself
[Music]